we have three expressions here this is
2/3 times 7/8 the second expression is 8
7 times 2/3 this third expression is 5
times 2 over 3 times 5 and what I want
you to do is pause this video right now
and think about which of these
expressions is the largest which is 1
which one is in the middle in terms of
in terms of value and which one is this
smallest and I want you to think about
it without actually doing the
calculation if you could just look at
them and figure out which of these is
the largest which of these is the
smallest and which of these is in the
middle so pause the video now now you
might have taken a shot at it and I'll
give you a little bit of a hint in case
you might in case you had trouble with
it all of these involve multiplying
something by two-thirds and you see a
2/3 here you see a 2/3 here and it might
not be as obvious but you also see a 2/3
here let me rewrite that to make a
little bit clearer so this first
expression could be re-written as 7 over
8 times 2/3 this second expression here
could be written as what's already
written as 8 over 7 times 2/3 times 2/3
and then this is the last expression we
could write it as in the numerator 5
times 2 5 times 2 and then in the
denominator it's over 5 times 3 5 times
3 which is of course the same thing as 5
over 5 times 2/3 times 2/3 so you see
all three of these expressions involved
something times 2/3 now I'm looking at
it this way does it become easier to
pick out which of these are the largest
which of these are the smallest and
which are these are someplace in between
I encourage you to pause it again if you
haven't thought about it yet so let's
visualize each of these expressions by
first trying to visualize 2/3 so let's
say the height of what I'm drawing right
now let's say the height of this bar
right over here is 2/3 so this right
over here represents 2/3 the height the
height here is 2/3 is
two thirds so first let's think about
what this one on the right here
represents this is five over five times
two thirds
well what's five over five five over
five is the same thing as one this is
literally just one times two thirds this
whole expression is the same thing as
one times two thirds or really just two
thirds so this the height here two
thirds this is the same thing as this
thing over here this is going to be
equal to this could also be viewed as
five times two over three times five
which was this first expression right
over here now let's think about what
these would look like so this is 7/8
times two-thirds so it's less than eight
eighths times two-thirds it's less than
one times two thirds so we're going to
scale two thirds down this is going to
be less than two thirds it's going to be
seven eighths of two thirds so this one
right over here this one right over here
would look something like this would
look something let me see if I could
draw it
yeah it would look something like
something like this if the yellow height
is two thirds then this right over here
then this height this height right over
here we draw make it clear this height
right over here would be seven eighths
times two thirds likewise let's look at
this one right over here let's look at
this one in the middle eight seven times
two thirds well eight seven is bigger
than seven sevens it's more than one
this is more than two thirds this is one
and 1/7 times two thirds so it's going
to be the same height as two-thirds plus
another seventh so it's going to look
something it's going to look something
like this it's going to look something
like this
so it's height now we scaled the two
thirds up because eight seven is greater
than one so this right over here this
height is going to be eight over seven
times two-thirds so the way that you
could have spotted which of these is the
largest in which of these is the
smallest is to say well what how are
they scaling two thirds this one right
over here you're essentially multiplying
two thirds by one so you're you're
or you're just going to get 2/3 you're
not scaling it up or you aren't scaling
it down this one right over here you're
scaling 2/3 down you are multiplying it
by something less than one if you
multiply it by something less than one
then you were going to be scaling it
down I should say a positive number or a
number between 0 & 1 less than 1 then
you're going to be scaling it down so
this thing is scaled down it's going to
be the smallest and here you're
multiplying the 2/3 times the number
bigger than 1 by 1 and 1/7 so you're
going to scale it up so this expression
is the largest 8 7 times 2/3 the
smallest is 2/3 times 7/8 and this one
right over here is in between